Have you ever seen...?
Have you ever seen a day like this?
I saw a day like this 20 years ago.
I have been coming here since I let her go.
Have you ever had...?
Have you ever had a dream like this?
In my entire life, I have only known...
...only one person whose heart I could call my own.
I have tried many times to find someone new.
So far, I have not found someone to replace you.
On the night we met, that night it was a first and last.
I remember thinking of which question I should ask.
I looked in your eyes as deep as I had ever done.
I remember knowing that for me you were the one.
First question that I asked you when I met you was,...
"Have you ever loved this face before?"
And you did not say, "No". You said, "Not yet".
You did not say, "No".
No, no, no, no.
You did not say, "No". You said, "Not yet".
You did not say, "No".
First question that I asked you when I met you was,...
"Have you ever loved this face before?"